[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
SIDDHARTH BHAI: Hey everyone.
Welcome.
Thank you for coming.
Good to see we have
nobody napping yet.
I know it's an hour
or so after lunch.
So thanks so much
for staying awake.
To get you a little
bit warmed up.
I thought I'd ask you
a quick show of hands.
How many of you are familiar
with Active Directory?
All right, great, so you're
in the right session.
Good to know.
That's pretty much
all of the room.
And for the three people who
maybe didn't raise their hands,
it's OK.
There is many resources
you can go check out later.
The other question,
how many of you
have had some experience
with Google Cloud Platform,
getting a VM up,
creating a network
and doing some basic
infrastructure as a service?
OK, so this is probably
about half the room.
And pretty much everyone
has experience with AD.
That's great.
So you're in the right session.
We're going to be
talking about how
you can extend your on-premises
Active Directory to Google
Cloud Platform.
My name is Siddharth Bhai.
I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
I focus on problems that work
with identity and security.
I'm really excited
to talk to you today,
and even more excited
to have with me two
very talented co-presenters.
BENJAMIN MILLER: Hi
there, Ben Miller.
I'm a systems
administrator with Google.
I work on the Mergers and
Acquisitions Infrastructure
Services Team.
KENNY HILL: How
are you guys doing?
I'm Kenny Hill.
I'm with Capital One Identity
and Access Management.
I focus on directories
in the cloud.
SIDDHARTH BHAI: Great.
So we'll go ahead
and get started.
So what I thought I'd start
off with is honesty an apology.
I'm sorry we're
not going to cover
the heated issue of
whether we should call it
on-premises, or on-premise,
or on-premise, or on-prem.
We will take that away
to the evening hours.
But two things in particular
I leave you with today.
One is, as the show of
hands showed, a lot of you
do have Active
Directory deployed,
and so we understand that.
And B is leave you with some
best practices and guidance
on how you can extend
your Active Directory
investments you have already
made onto the Google Cloud
Platform.
So in particular, the
things we'll encounter is,
how is it that you can use your
on-premises Active Directory
where you do your
users and groups
management to get identity
and access management
configure on GCP?
We'll talk about some drivers
and architecture choices
for actually running
AD on GCP itself.
After that, we'll have
two great case studies
coming up of actual experiences
of having run AD on GCP.
And we'll round it off
with some best practices.
So the first thing that
we're going to cover is,
how can you extend your
on-premises Active Directory
users and groups onto GCP for
identity and access management?
This is probably
the question I get
asked most often over the last
year or so because a lot of you
have put in that investment
to start working to have
Active Directory all set up.
Auditors are happy.
Internal security team has
signed off, which is great.
And now you want to start
getting started with GCP.
So can you leverage those
existing investments?
And the answer is yes.
And I'll show you how
in the next two slides.
What's coming up is probably
a fairly familiar typology
to a lot of you.
You probably have
your users in groups
in your on-premises
Active Directory.
They're sitting in your Active
Directory domain controllers.
And then for a
variety of reasons,
several customers have
either EDFS, or PING,
or [? Octar, ?] any of these
other federation products
supply it, so you can take
those on-premises users
and get single sign-on to
a variety of other relying
parties or applications.
And so the question is, when
the application is Google Cloud
Platform itself, how is it
that you can connect the two?
So a canonical use
case that comes up
as we often find that as
customers, maybe somebody gets
interested with
BigQuery and wants
to go ahead and set things up
so that a certain group of users
can go ahead and do
things with BigQuery.
So the way that you do in GCP
is via rule-based authorization.
So if you were BigQuery
admin, you could then go ahead
and essentially do a variety
of things with BigQuery.
So how do you set it up?
I have this slide coming up.
I'll let you soak
it in for a second.
It's Google Cloud identity
There's a lot of
things on this slide.
And it's a full identity
as-a-service product.
I won't be going too
deep into it today,
but I did want you to
know it has identity,
it has policies, a very strong
support for device management.
But there's two
features in particular,
which is all we need for
the question we set it out
to answer.
And those two features
are A, it allows
you to sync your users and
groups from on-premises Active
Directory onto a Google
Cloud Identity domain.
B, you can set up your
Google Cloud identity domain
to indicate that you'd like the
authentication of those users
to happen with your on-premises
federation end point.
And by going ahead and
using these two features,
you can have your users and
groups from on-premises Active
Directory be used for BigQuery
or any other IM in GCP.
So let's go ahead and take
a look at that in this demo.
OK, so as that screen comes
up, what you're looking at
should seem pretty
familiar to a lot of you
since you're experienced
with Active Directory.
This is the Active Directory
Administrative Center.
And for the--
OK-- purpose of the demo, I need
to go ahead and re-establish
my RDP.
As it comes up,
what you'll see is
I have a Active Directory
Administrative Center open
in the on-premises environment.
Great.
So this should look familiar.
It is your on-premises
Active Directory.
I have created an OU in here for
GCP which is currently black.
So I'll go ahead and run a
simple PowerShell script.
And what the script has done is
it's gone ahead and pre-created
for you some users and groups.
So as I refresh,
I have three users
in my on-premises Active
Directory, Alice, Bob
and Charlie.
And I have a group,
GCP Security Admins,
which has Alice and
Bob as its members.
So this is what we have set
up in your on-premises AD,
probably simulates a lot of
deployments you have today.
I'll now go ahead
and switch onto a VM
where I have Google Cloud
directory sync set up.
So what this is doing is it'll
go ahead and take the users
from that OU and groups and
sync it up to a Google Cloud
identity domain.
So one thing I should
call out is a lot of you,
if you've been using GCP,
G Suite in particular
for a while, you may be
familiar of a term Google
domain, which is the same thing
as a Google Cloud identity
domain.
So I'll go ahead
and sync these up.
What this is doing it that's now
pushing those users and groups
into Google.
So I'll switch my screens.
And what you are now looking
at is the Admin Console
for Google Cloud identity.
So I refresh my screen.
The three users we just
created, Alice, Bob and Charlie,
are now available in the
Google Cloud identity domain.
And as I go to the group's
UI, you'll see the group.
GCP Security Admin is
also available here.
So I'll go ahead
and take this group,
and it's now all come up from
your on-premises AD into GCP.
So what's next?
Now, let's go back to the
thing we were trying to do.
To do that, I'll
apply this group.
You're now looking at the
IM page of a GCP project.
And I'll go ahead
and add a role.
I'll give the users of this
particular group, which we just
synced them from you on-premises
AD, the role of BigQuery admin.
And so as I go
ahead and hit Save,
you now see that this
group has BigQuery admin
IM on this project.
Now, the interesting thing here
as we come back to our slides
is effectively that you
have this set of groups--
these set of users
who can be added
in a lot of you
on-premises AD group
and have the access changes
reflected back on GCP IM
without needing to go ahead
and do anything special
into this IM page.
So as we come back to our slides
please, what you will notice
is we will have two
additional items coming up
onto this IM policy that I
just showed you pretty soon.
One is you will be able to
say that allow of these users
to only have access for
a specific time window.
So the one at the top is
the policy we just set up.
But down below is a
special expression
that will allow you to
essentially have your group
sync ahead of time and say
only for that hour, or only
for that month are those
users allowed to have access.
And second is you'll be
able to further restrict it
based on the source IPs
that they're actually
connecting from.
So that's the first part
of the session where
we saw how you can
use it on-premises AD,
extend it onto GCP,
and use that for IM.
And this is where we come to
an interesting transition.
And it's a slightly tricky point
to make, so I need your help.
Everything we looked at so far
was having your on-premises
AD, extend it on to GCP
without requiring VPN
by syncing your users and
groups into your GCP domain.
What we now go
and take a look at
is if you are
trying to run Active
Directory or
AD-related apps on GCP,
how do you go ahead and do that?
And for this, we do not
need Cloud identity or a VPN
to be set up for the things
we're going to talk about next.
So that's something.
So a lot of times when you need
Active Directory in the cloud
is if you were thinking
of a migration project.
So go ahead and soak in
that visual for a second,
and I'll talk through it.
So what you're seeing is you
have an application that's
talking to your
on-premises Active
Directory over a set of
Active Directory protocols.
Now, what are the cases when
you may need Active Directory
as you think of moving this
app or this server onto GCP?
So one very common
use case is if you
have gone ahead
and domain-joined
these applications onto
Google Cloud Platform--
onto Active Directory,
and you want to run them
on Google Cloud Platform.
So in that case,
you're looking for AD.
In other cases, if the app does
LDAP, or Kerberos, or Windows
Integrated Auth, it's looking
for a domain controller.
The next set of
things is if the app
has logic for
retrieving things that
are stored in Active
Directory itself,
most often it's
group-based membership when
the application houses
authorization logic in itself.
Another time is if you had
used an AD client-side library.
For instance, you
had a .NET-based app.
And if that was
making any calls over
to System.DirectoryServices,
it would look
to find a domain controller.
And the last bit is, when
you do go ahead and have
your application
migrated to the cloud,
you have a choice to make,
which is do you still
want your on-premise network
to be on the critical path
for each application
authentication look up?
Or would you rather
have it scale in cloud,
have low latency,
and have the cloud
application be independently
and highly available.
So how is it that these
choices end up manifesting
your architecture options?
Let's take a look.
First thing you can do in any
of these cases is the simplest,
just go ahead and set up your
VPN or a Cloud Interconnect
and have your Active Directory
continue to recite on-premises.
And so this way,
it's pretty quick
to configure but you have
higher latency for all
your applications.
Every single request
is going back
to your on-premises network.
So what do you do?
Second option you have
is you can go ahead
and choose to deploy
read-only domain
controllers onto Google Cloud.
Now, the advantage
in this case is
it's a read-only replica
of Active Directory.
But those are you who
have worked with it
for a while would
probably know that there
are certain operations that are
still being chained or referred
back to your full domain
controllers, which in this case
would reside on-premises.
So you're absolutely going back
to your on-premises network
for getting those done.
In terms of a
positive, this does not
bring in everybody's credentials
onto any cloud deployments.
So you can have no
users' passwords
in the cloud by
default. Some of you
may like that from a
security perspective.
However, it also lets
you only have replicated
in a certain set
of users' passwords
into that cloud AD deployment.
On the other hand, the
biggest challenge with RODCs
is there's application
compatibility
things you should think about.
So if you go in Google for
RODC application compatibility,
the first link gives
you a list of apps
that support RODCs or not.
So that's something
to factor in.
The next option is to go ahead
and deploy your writeable
or regular domain
controllers into cloud.
And in this case, you obviously
have your Active Directory data
available entirely on GCP.
It's low latency because
your application is then
going for all operations to
the ADDC you just apply there.
However, the thing to
keep in mind in both this
as well as the
previous configure
is if you have multiple
Active Directory domains,
you may end up needing to deploy
domain controllers for each
of those domains into cloud.
So if you had a merger
and acquisition use case
or for any other reasons had
three or four AD domains,
[INAUDIBLE] multiple domain
controllers from each of those
domains.
So to get around that,
another thing you can do
is set up a new Active
Directory domain on Google Cloud
Platform, use the Active
Directory trust relationship
model to establish a trust
with your on-premise AD.
And this does work well
because you effectively
are able to have three or four
different AD domains where
our users are having
their credentials stored
and authentication happening.
However, all your resources
and applications, which
are running in the
cloud, can join
or just work against the Active
Directory domain which is now
hosted fully within Cloud.
Another thing you
could think about when
you think of moving to the cloud
and having a hybrid deployment
is to consider having a disaster
recovery site on Google Cloud
Platform.
And so the numbers you're
seeing on the right
effectively show an example
of AD site replication
costs, which you could utilize
to go ahead and have things set
up so that your users and
applications on-premises
are usually not reaching
back to the cloud.
And only in the
event of a failover
will they come in and
use the cloud DCs.
So these are five options you
have in terms of architecture.
And by this point,
you're probably
wondering, which of these makes
sense for your specific use
case?
Now, to help answer
that, I'm really
excited to share with you
the highlight of our segment
today, which is the
Ben & Kenny experience.
They'll come up
and share with you
what is it that worked
for them as they
look to have AD running on GCP.
KENNY HILL: Hi again, guys.
First, I want to
thank Sid, I want
to thank Ben for allowing
me to come up here and share
a little bit about Capital One's
Google Cloud Active Directory
journey.
Hopefully there's time
at the end for questions.
If not, feel free to connect.
Always really
excited to hear what
others are doing in the
identity and directory
space in the cloud.
See the question up on
the board-- or screen.
Why extend Active
Directory to Google Cloud?
There are many reasons.
The main driver for us
is resiliency and speed.
Let me explain a little
bit of what that means
and some of the design
inputs that went
into some of our decisions.
There are four main areas
we focus on with our domain
controller design.
First one, security.
I'm going to gloss
over that and skip it.
Not enough time for me
to really dive deep.
Ben is going to share
some security practices.
Next area for us
is directory size.
Since going on on
the cloud, we've
had exponential growth
in our directories,
running at a 38 and 60 gigabit.
NTDS did have about 2.5 million
objects in each directory,
between 100,000, 150,000
both users and group objects.
Understanding
directory size, there's
many reasons for our growth.
One of the main ones
that I'm excited about
is the development we've had on
Cloud Platform of applications
requiring role-based access.
We've also taken the
concept of tags from cloud,
and we're writing more
data into our directory.
This is allows us to correlate
Active Directory objects
with Cloud things utilizing
our provisioning system.
Next, there is a resiliency.
The next is speed.
As I was doing the
slides for this,
I realized same inputs
really went into both of them
to ensure Active
Directory authentication
and authorization
is always available.
Doesn't matter if it's a
federated SAML authentication,
a Windows authentication, LDAP
Application bind, a database
authentication, the
directory needs to be there.
Same holds true when your
domain-joining infrastructure,
and it wants to scale.
So the directory
needs to be there.
So for us, going down
Interconnect or VPN, that
wasn't really an
option as we want to,
no matter the situation, ensure
that we can scale applications.
To create a seamless
experience for applications
when switching projects
in regions, a developer,
application team, DevOps team,
no matter what you call them,
they should not need to know
anything about AD sites,
maintain different URL mappings.
We even have application
teams that they don't even
know it's Active
Directory on the backend.
When they need help, they
ask where's the LDAP team?
To provide the fastest
domain-join directory
replication and LDAP
experience possible.
A key way to be
successful in this bullet
is to keeping your
traffic on Google Cloud.
I'm not going to give
exact time test metrics.
You guys, I highly recommend
testing this yourself.
In a world where every
millisecond counts
it is important to
ensure that traffic
stays on the most optimal path.
And this is probably one
of the biggest reasons
we build domain controllers
on Compute Engine,
to quickly rehydrate and be
able to increase AD capacity.
At Capital One, we
rebuild all infrastructure
every 45 to 60 days maximum.
Domain controllers are no
exception to that rule.
They get rebuilt. We
call this rehydrate.
So we are constantly rebuilding
our domain controllers.
That's why directory
size is up there.
You need to understand
your build times.
It's important to
know exactly how
long it's going to take to
build domain controllers.
Even if using the
install for media file,
which you back up the AD
database or SYSVOL you
import it.
If you have quite a
few objects, the domain
promote process is still
going to do a checksum--
I don't know the correct term
for it-- but of every object.
And that's where the
lag's going to happen.
So understanding your
directory size and the speed
that you can build
domain controllers is
going to help you determine is
your directory's small enough?
Are you able to auto scale?
If so, I'm jealous.
Or are you going to
have to run it, monitor
it a little bit over your
monitoring high peaks,
meaning you're running a little
bit over capacity at all times,
or do you keep a reserve pool of
live domain controllers running
on smaller instances
in a reserved AD site
and utilize scaling
technology to bring them
in and out as you need them?
Next, I'm going to show you a
few of the high-level design
decisions.
In a traditional
AD site typology,
for on-premise you'd
usually have a single AD
site or two per data center.
Each of these AD
sites is usually
going to have some sort
of single point of failure
if it's power, network,
shared storage,
or other infrastructure.
In our Google Cloud
model, we utilize--
we put domain
controllers in every zone
available in each
region we deploy.
This is essentially
treating the whole region
as a single AD site.
This provides a more
resilient typology.
In the on-premise model it's
hard to test if you can-- you
manage your sites and
services, and your cost,
and you for the
next closest site,
and there can be errors in it.
You can shut down network to a
data center, and you can say--
and you can know that
everything's authenticated
and authorization's
occurring, but do you
know exactly where
all that's going?
In this model in the
cloud, you know it's just
staying in the same site.
This also ensures that any
applications that utilize DC
locator process are going
to pick domain controller
in the AD site, in
region, staying on Google
Cloud as their primary.
For applications that
cannot utilize DC locator,
we utilize an LDAP
load balancer.
Our configuration for load
balancer LDAP secure 636, GCS
global catalog secure 3269
coming into the load balancer.
This ensures that all traffic
outside of the project
is secure.
We then terminate at the load
balancer to regular 3893268
and point at domain controllers
across multiple zones.
Realize global catalog
secure port for applications
which chase referrals.
Many Java-based applications
chase referrals.
And sometimes you have COTS
products deployed which you
cannot disable in.
If you're not familiar
with chase referrals,
it's when you point an
application to a domain
controller, and instead
of utilizing that domain
controller, it pulls
back all the A records
and randomizes
them per the client
and then just
picks a random one.
If you utilize
global catalog port,
it disables referral chasing.
We're predominantly
a Linux shop,
which does not have DC
locator process by default
without third-party products.
There are also many applications
which are not AD site aware,
they cannot utilize
a load balancer,
or even some of the horrible
applications that you have
to point directly to
a domain controller.
An example of one of
those applications
you'd point directly
at a domain controller
is something that
needs to read and write
almost simultaneously,
like your identity
and lifecycle management
application or provisioning
application where if it doesn't
read and write at the same one,
you could have collisions.
We utilize a root DSE
query, so LDAPS route
DSE query to the load balancer
returning the DNS hostname.
The applications
can utilize this.
They can put it in
a script or a job
and ensure their configuration
is always pointing
at a live domain controller.
Even if we're rebuilding
or rehydrating
our domain controllers, if
they have this job set up,
they'll know they always have
a live domain controller.
As I mentioned, it is
extremely important
to ensure we are replicating
Active Directory data
as fast as possible
in this model.
If we were to fail
to another region,
applications need to be able
to read the same data that they
read in one region
in another one.
Also allows us to
more effectively get
to adjust in-time
access model and enhance
our privileged access
password rotation.
The legacy replication strategy
was designed more than 18 years
ago when network was slow
and also very expensive.
We choose to utilize a full
mass replication with change
notification strategy.
Change notification treats
replication on the site link
same as it would in our site.
Though the diagram
I'm showing up there,
we are replicating from
site to site on-premise
to all of our Google regions.
And then we do,
as fast as we can,
replication between the sites.
To close out, a couple
more lessons that we've
learned along the way.
Limit your use of
group policy objects.
There are many more
cloud-friendly configuration
management solutions out there.
Ben's going to actually show you
one that's available for free
that works.
You can also utilize-- you
can also harden your image,
stack all your configuration
settings in your image.
And that's another approach.
Managing group policy deviations
and exceptions in a cloud model
is not operationally efficient
for the directory support
teams or the application teams.
The application teams are
going to need to script
moving the objects or adding to
a security filter group, which
means they need credentials,
which means they have
to also have secure a password.
So we don't take that
approach, we only
deploy GPO for high-level
settings, which there's
no way we're going to reverse.
Monitor and log everything.
Even if you're not going to
utilize the data immediately,
you will want it later.
There are many other services
besides Compute Engine
which can enhance directory
services in the cloud.
So you will want
this historical data
when you're building out tools
and applications on Google
Cloud Platform.
Automate your domain
controller build.
I already mentioned this one.
It's worth repeating.
Ensure your build process
for domain controllers
is efficient, and you're
able to quickly add capacity.
Domain controllers are
in a different category
of core services than
regular applications.
The domain controllers
need to be there
before the applications
need to consume it.
Another thing is AD, of
you who are very familiar,
It's extremely chatty.
Wait until you put
it in the cloud.
When teens are auto-scaling
they're spinning up
1,000 instances at a
time, pulling them down,
AD's to be chattier.
So being able to add capacity
really quick is important.
Last thing I'll leave you with.
At Capital One, we do not
troubleshoot isolated domain
controller issues in the cloud.
We will give it one reboot.
If that issue persists,
domain controller comes out,
we bring another one in.
Thank you guys for sitting
and listening to me.
Thank you, Sid.
[APPLAUSE]
SIDDHARTH BHAI:
That was actually
a very, very interesting
set of experiences
that you heard Capital
One talk about how they're
running Active Directory
in production on GCP
with a fairly large size.
The two angles in particular
that stood out for me was one
is, even when you are
looking to run something
like Active Directory, which
is a very core Windows Server
workload trying to do LDAP, by
leveraging Cloud DNS and Cloud
load balancing, it
was interesting to see
how they designed the
LDAP load balancer.
That's definitely
something-- things like this
as you go out and explore
of moving to the cloud are
interesting ideas to try.
The second was the
message that we
were left with which is,
you should go ahead and look
to automate your domain
controller creation,
the domain controller
build process.
And that's actually
a great point.
And I'm excited to
call upon Ben who
is going to come in and share
with us more about what is it
that Alphabet does when
it also deploys domain
controllers in production.
And how is it that you've
automated DC Build.
Welcome Ben.
BENJAMIN MILLER: Hi.
As I mentioned a bit ago, I work
on Google's M&A Infrastructure
Services Team.
I work with a group
of talented systems
administrators in
Colorado and California
that built and operate
the project that I'm going
to be talking about today.
One of the things
that our team does
is to build and maintain
core it infrastructure
for an array of acquisitions
and partnerships.
To make this happen, we rely
heavily on code and automation.
Our project, GECCO,
is code-driven managed
IT infrastructure for Alphabet
entities and acquisitions
deployed in Google Cloud.
The problem that
we set out to solve
was consistent management of
many unrelated Active Directory
domains rather than
a single large forest
as Kenny was describing.
With a fairly small
team, we manage
services like Active
Directory, DNS, DHTP, MPS,
and Radius for many small to
medium-sized environments.
In order to
accomplish this, we've
put tremendous focus on
using the DevOps approach
of infrastructure as code.
Using code and automation
to deploy and maintain
these environments and
minimizing manual changes.
So I'd like to share some
of the key design goals that
informed the design of GECCO.
And I propose that these
are goals that most of you
would share if you were
building out domain
infrastructure in Google Cloud.
I'll give you some
examples of how
we got to where we are,
but just understand
there are many other ways
to achieve the same goals.
So let me break each
one of these down.
First, it's important
to limit access
to the GCP products that contain
your domain infrastructure.
Protecting your
domain controllers
from malicious or
accidental action
is critical to the security
of these environments.
So we build domain
infrastructure
in isolated GCP projects.
Having ownership or
instance admin roles in GCE
means having tremendous
power over the instances that
run in those projects.
For example, depending on
your IAM roles in the project,
you can create or
delete instances,
you can access their logs,
create new Windows accounts,
and change passwords
on those machines.
So we as role accounts
and custom IAM
grants to give just
the access needed
to resources in our projects.
We only allow folks
that are domain admins
in the environment to become
instance admins in the projects
that they run in.
We carefully consider
the consequences
of granting even lesser
access to compute resources
in the projects that contain
these domain controllers.
Approach every Cloud IAM grant
by asking yourself, can you--
can someone use this access
to escalate their privileges
in the domain?
Will this grant let someone
modify instances, metadata,
or access sensitive logs?
So now, we built our domain
controllers in an isolated
project, fantastic.
They're running
perfectly, smoothly.
Nothing's is going wrong,
they're under glass,
and nobody can talk to them.
So what do we do next?
First, we use instance tags to
define VPC firewall rules that
control the flow of network
traffic within our project.
This ensures that we know
where all of our traffic
is coming from and
where it is going to.
Once these rules
are in place, we
can establish
network connections
to our customers' cloud
and on-prem environments.
We want our infrastructure to
be available and performant,
so we do a couple of things.
We co-locate our instances
in the same GCP zones
that our customer
projects run in.
And then we use
Cloud VPC Peering
to create fast
network connections
between the virtual
private cloud
networks of these projects.
Finally, we interact with
on-prem networks via cloud VPN,
again, placing our compute
instances in cloud regions that
are close to those network.
Our next design goal was
to automate provisioning
and to implement
source-controlled configuration
management.
Infrastructure as code is key
to scaling IT as a service.
But we're not just
concerned with shaving down
provisioning time.
By centralizing our code,
and config, and source
repositories, we can
force all changes
to go through peer review
and a suite of tests.
And with sufficient provisioning
and configuration automation,
you might choose to build
new instances rather
than applying updates
to existing ones,
as Kenny described.
You can bring new
instances online
and ensure they are operating
correctly before bringing
your existing capacity offline.
And with GECCO, our instance
provisioning automation
is built around getting our
configuration management
in place as early as
possible and making sure
that it stays in control.
So we automate deployment
of new domain controllers
and other instance types
using a couple of stages.
So for the first stage
of our instance build,
we take advantage of
the CIS prep specialized
stage of Windows installation
to inject our build artifacts
onto the machine.
This is possible
thanks to the GCE agent
that runs in this
stock GCE image
that we build our instance from.
It will look for a script
configured in the project
or instance metadata, and
then it will run that script.
All we are doing in
this initial stage
is to download build artifacts
from a canonical source.
So here I've highlighted a
very short PowerShell script
where I'm storing--
that I'm storing as a
value in a hash table.
And when I pass that hash
table to the command below,
the key value pairs in the hash
table become instance metadata.
So when I provisioned
the machine,
the GCE agent will go looking
for the specialized script
and metadata.
And upon finding it,
it will execute it.
As I said, all this
particular script
is doing is copying instance
build artifacts from GCS.
Now, I could, instead of
using a Git repository,
or I could be using a package
repository, or something else.
The important thing
is that all of the
build artifacts
that I'm using are
coming from a vetted source.
Everything I'm using
to build this instance
should be centrally stored.
Everything that I'm using
to build this instance
should be peer
reviewed or should
be built by something that
was itself peer reviewed.
After the CIS prep
specialized stage completes
and the instance reboots,
our second stage script
is triggered.
Now, this script will install
configuration management
prerequisites, initialize
the configuration management
system, and then shepherd
it through its first run
of config management
to make sure
that it completes successfully.
For our domain controllers, we
use PowerShell Desired State
Configuration as our
configuration management
system.
So here I've given
you an example
of the DSC
configuration required
to create a brand new domain
controller on a Windows Server
Core machine.
That's really about it.
The WindowsFeature DSC resource
ensures that the AD Domain
Services feature is installed
and the XAD domain resource
handles the creation
of the domain.
In a production
environment, you're
going to see a lot of additional
code and configuration
to handle things like credential
management, and testing,
and other things that are
specifically our environment.
But this really is all there is
to creating a new domain using
PowerShell DSC.
Speaking of
credential management,
the final thing I
wanted to touch on
was protecting your secrets.
Building domain
infrastructure necessitates
handling some very important
credentials, including
those you needed to create
a new domain controller,
or a new domain entirely.
Everyone at some point
is going to be tempted
to put a password in a script.
We've all been around
the block, don't do it.
Don't use plain text.
Don't just use obfuscation.
Rot13 is not encryption.
[LAUGHTER]
Really encrypt your secrets.
Store them in a place where
you will have an audit trail
every time they are accessed.
And have sufficient
logging in place
to know when those
credentials are used anywhere
in your environment.
So there are a lot of ways
to protect your credentials,
but I wanted to show you a
pretty simple example that's
enabled by Cloud Key Management
Service, or Cloud KMS.
Cloud KMS allows you to
encrypt and decrypt secrets
based on Cloud
IAM access grants.
So, I can have one
set of accounts
that has permissions
just to encrypt secrets,
and then I can have another
set of accounts that just has
permission to decrypt secrets.
Here I'm using a very
simple gcloud command
to encrypt a plain
text string and store
the results in a file.
Then I'm uploading that file
to Google Cloud Storage.
And when I need to use
this very secure password
to join my domain
controller to my domain,
the code can retrieve the
encrypted file from GCS,
decrypt the secret, and inject
it into my configuration
management without the plain
text password ever landing
on disk.
Now, we could, if you imagine,
just take things a step further
and build a process
where no human ever
has to know what
certain passwords are.
So you can imagine having
a process to generate
a new random password as part
of an automated provisioning
process.
So let's say that I have a
password for a break glass
administrative account.
The right service account
in the right place
will be able to access
this secret in order
to set the password for
the break glass account.
But no human will ever
have to know what this is.
If OnCall uses Cloud KMS
to decrypt the secret,
I'll know about it
thanks to my audit logs.
And the same process
can be triggered again
to automatically
rotate the password.
So in summary, when building
domain infrastructure in GCP,
you should carefully consider
these aspects of your design--
limiting access to
just where it is needed
and isolating your
domain infrastructure,
automating your
provisioning and deployment
and using configuration
management,
and protecting your
critical secrets.
Thank you very much.
I'll hand the rest of
the time back to Sid.
[APPLAUSE]
SIDDHARTH BHAI: Thank you
Ben so much for joining us.
The two key takeaways I
think from this segment
for me were, one is like
an operational step-by-step
of how can you
actually automate DC
build using tooling,
which is hopefully
familiar to a lot
of you who have been
working with AD for a while.
Second was you saw Ben talk
about what's a good way
to go ahead and protect secrets
in the cloud in this case,
for the Active
Directory use case,
but using Cloud KMS and GCS
during the encrypted secret,
it's something you can extend
for other applications you
do with GCP, too.
As we go into this final
section of the talk,
I wanted to go ahead and
touch upon and bring together
some of these best practices.
This is obviously
not a complete list.
You've heard some very
great pearls of wisdom
from both Ben and Kenny.
But thought I'd leave
you with a few things
to keep in mind as
you start thinking
about running Active
Directory or extending it
to Google Cloud.
The first set of things is
around Active Directory design.
So one of the things
you should think about
as you move to cloud
is, there's no reason
to not be highly available.
So for domain
controllers, always
have at least two
DCs, one in each zone.
Second, when you think about
your Active Directory site
topology, you have two options.
One is you can pick a
simple option, which
is you create a single Active
Directory site for all of GCP.
And using the power of
our multi-regional VPC,
you're effectively able
to have that work well.
It's a quick way to get started.
Second, you heard Kenny
describe, especially as you
move towards more
performant applications,
to have one site per region.
And what this will do is for any
of the applications or servers
you have running in that
region, they will always
go to the closest
domain controller
and you'll see low latencies.
In terms of connectivity
back to on-premises
there's networking options,
Cloud VPN, Cloud Interconnect.
You're welcome to
go study those more
and see which one
works well for you.
That's because a lot of
Active Directory operations
require non-internet,
like private network,
line-of-sight connectivity
between domain controllers
as many of you are
probably aware.
The last part is, for any
applications or servers
you choose to move
to GCP, and you
do have one or more AD
sites on GCP, placing them
in the same Active
Directory site
will lead to the
right type of things
happening, which should
keep your DNS and AD
operations working well,
finding the closest DC.
For an operations
and security angle,
a few things to keep in mind.
One is there's obviously
a plethora of choices
when you come to cloud
for running Compute.
You obviously want to
make, just like you
would if you were
purchasing hardware,
to run your domain controllers
make the right type of choices.
Preemptable VMs may be cool,
but probably not a good idea
for running AD
domain controllers.
You want to think about static
IPs and things like that.
In terms of GCP IM
permissions, you
saw that being something
we covered in last two case
studies, but I did want
to hone in the point.
Here's something
to keep in mind.
If you have a domain controller
running in a VM on Compute,
anybody who has Compute Instance
admin on that GCP project
can go right click,
reset Windows password,
and effectively elevate
themselves to a domain admin.
Now just like you wouldn't
very loosely put your Active
Directory on-premises
domain controllers
in physical environments
you didn't fully trust,
when it comes to managing it in
the cloud, especially in GCP,
you want to be mindful of
which type of IM permissions
you have on those projects.
In particular, anybody
with a set IM policy
is able to set IM permissions
on that GCP project
and give themselves or
other a variety of IM roles.
So it's generally a good
hygiene to keep in mind,
but especially when you're
running domain controllers,
be mindful of that.
Second, we have a
resource hierarchy
within GCP, which is beyond
the scope of this talk today.
But to give you an
idea, you can have
projects, which are inside
of folders, which are inside
of organizations.
And so there is a inheritance
model of IM permissions
there too.
So I see several of you nodding.
I won't go into more detail.
But something to study
and keep in mind as you're
thinking of running AD.
Lastly, if you wish to
have more isolation for AD,
you can always set up a Bastian
Active Directory Project.
It is more things that
you'll have to configure,
but I did want you to know that
is an option for high security
cases.
You can then still use VPC
Peering and shared VPCs
to have all your domain
controllers in that project,
but have your servers
and applications
and other projects
that can still
reach those domain controllers.
Lastly, there is a
session later this week--
I have a link in a
couple of slides--
which we'll talk about how
you can use hardened security
on Google Cloud Platform for
all of your sensitive workloads,
including AD.
So I encourage you to
find out more about that
and look to leverage that.
So if all of this is
sounding interesting to you,
and you when it gets
started, I wanted
to leave you with just a
few quick slides of examples
of things you can do.
One is we have a Google
Cloud solution that talks you
through step by
step how you can get
your highly available Active
Directory domain up on GCP.
I have a slide with all
the links in a minute
if you want to take
a photo of that.
Second is, you can also choose
to extend an existing AD
domain onto GCP.
So there is a white paper.
Phase three of this white paper
talks about Active Directory
considerations.
There is a click to deploy.
If you wanted to go ahead and
just get and AD domain spun up,
and start playing with it,
and experimenting with it,
we have that, something you
can go ahead and leverage.
And a lot of what
you have heard today
is focused around two themes.
One is having high available,
multi-regional Active Directory
on GCP.
And B has been
around specifically
automating domain
controller creation.
And so for that, I'm actually
very excited to share with you
what Itopia has done.
So Itopia-- excuse
me-- is a partner who
we've been working with for
the last several months.
They have a very
interesting set of things
they're announcing right
now at NEXT, in particular,
the ability to extend an
existing Active Directory
domain and the ability to
have multiple sites, one
site per region, similar to how
you heard Kenny advise and talk
about how they're doing
it in Capital One.
They have a booth down below
if you want to go and get
automated support for everything
that you've heard about today.
I encourage you to
go check them out.
So here are some
links if you wanted
to go back and play with that.
I wanted thank you
all for coming.
And please let us
know if there's
more we can do in GCP to
help support these use cases.
Thank you so much.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]